you know what i was watching you on and
i had such mixed emotions you did that
show uh between two friends with zach
galifianakis right uh and you know uh
it's a funny show yeah in that you're
sitting there and you're a good sport
because to me i liken it to a roast
yeah the guy sits you down and he says
every insulting thing he can think of
saying to paul rudd
and obviously he probably had a lot more
that he did not everything but but don't
you get i you know i could not do that
show because i would get offended oh no
he that's another guy
zach galifianakis yes that is one of the
funniest people i've ever met and have
ever seen like his whole
style i mean when he was doing i mean
before hangover when he was just doing
stand-up kind of starting off he was one
of my favorite comedians i just think
he's so funny and well he turns to you
in the show and he says uh
you know paul um couldn't you help other
jewish actors hide their jewishness
but i've never really tried to hide my
jewishness i've really never tried to
hide my jewishness i said that is the
greatest funniest line ever yeah but
then all of a sudden i was like i didn't
know paul was jewish he's been hiding
and you know he has been hiding his
jewishness i did not realize that
where'd you grow up again i grew up in
kansas i was born in here i was born
here i went to new jersey i then lived
in california i moved to kansas city
they don't have any jews in kansas they
do but they didn't go to my school
was it awful being serious like i've
gone to places you know i unlike you i
can't hide my jewishness
i was slapped to yamako when i was born
but when i but but seriously growing up
in kansas and there's no other jews
around
it's got to be terribly um well you got
to feel somewhat alienated i think at
least i was because of my dad's job and
he worked for an airline he was in
management for twa twa's hub was in
kansas city which is why we wound up
there but i was always a new kid in a
new school
from the time
of he was always getting job transfers
and things like that and so when i was
10 i'd already been in i don't know how
many schools um i think because my
parents were both british
that i had moved around i was always a
new kid in school
and i was jewish certainly in kansas
city and i knew that that was the i was
in the minority there i always felt a
little different than i guess most of
the kids and what i learned
earl kind of early on is that like if i
make jewish jokes about myself
um i noticed that all of the kids would
laugh really hard it wasn't until i got
older i'm like that's kind of that's
kind of messed up
yeah but um
were there a lot of like anti-semitic
comments and
hey jew boy and all that i got that yeah
i mean not
not a ton
right i mean i would think that the
majority of people probably didn't care
didn't right you know
what if they even knew it wasn't
anything i was i've never tried to hide
anything but uh i'm also not a
particularly religious person but
um you're not kidding you celebrate
christmas right yeah yeah well yeah yeah
there you go there you go
can't do any better than that
it's the best
it's the best
christmas is awesome oh man yes that's
my favorite part about being jewish